welcome to the science Asylum I am Nick
lucid the question we're answering in
this episode how do microwaves actually
cook normally you just throw your food
in push some buttons wait a few minutes
and voila your food is magically cooked
but what happens behind the curtain
there really isn't much on the inside
it's mostly empty space you've got a big
cooking space over here and almost all
the circuitry is crammed in over here
which is why the weight of the oven is
never centered well start this basic
tool from the moment you press start
okay so your wall socket provides about
a hundred and twenty volts give or take
the power cord carries that voltage into
the oven where it encounters something
called a transformer no no no a circuit
transformer that's better this
transformer is one of the simplest
electronic devices it has no moving
parts or digital parts of any kind and
it doesn't require any weird advanced
physics to understand it's made of a
very heavy iron block called a core with
three wire coils wrapped around it this
thing is so heavy it represents almost
the entire weight of the oven only one
of those coils connects to the power
cord which remember is 120 volts what
comes next is true genius they're called
transformers because they transform
voltage most transformers lower it
others raise it the one in the microwave
oven can do both remember it has three
coils total one for incoming power and
two for outgoing power this one takes
the voltage down about 36 times to about
3 volts the other one takes it up about
16 times to about 2,000 volts very
dangerous in fact when you hook it up
all by itself it does this that 2,000
volt line goes immediately into a big
honkin capacitor this capacitor is the
most dangerous part of the microwave the
problem with the capacitor is that it
stores electrical energy sometimes for
years or even decades ever been told not
to open a microwave
that's why anyway how the capacitor and
its peripherals work would require an
entire video to explain so I'll spare
you the agony and just say that it turns
the AC that you'd normally get into DC
the whole process inadvertently ends up
doubling the voltage basically it's like
having a 4,000 volt battery that never
dies
now that we have a 4000 volt line in a 3
volt line we can move forward
both of these are carried to the same
device the magnetron no no magnetron not
Megatron there that's better both the
voltage lines connect to the bottom of
the magnetron which is kind of a mini
particle accelerator I like to call it
an electron gun because that's what it
does
it fires electrons the 3 volts heats up
a piece of metal which makes the
electrons loose then the 4000 volts
pulls them off the metal and launches
them fast fast into the top part of the
magnetron where a couple of magnets
generated a magnetic field that looks
like this the moment these electrons get
launched into it they spin around in
circles those circles are what make the
microwave oven possible because light is
created
no no not visible light that have to be
going a lot faster for that these
electrons make microwaves God not the
oven the wave that's better the whole
thing is set up so the microwaves have a
frequency of two point four or five
gigahertz the frequency best absorbed by
water molecules the only way this is
possible is if those electrons are going
around that circle two and a half
billion times a second I meant it when I
said that fast see every substance has a
special frequency of light that at most
dislikes letting through blast for
example stops a type of ultraviolet
called UVB dead in its tracks it turns
that light into heat which is why your
car windows are so warm after they've
been sitting in the Sun all day water
does the same thing but with microwaves
it's the water in your food that cooks
your food the magnetron shines the
microwaves into the cooking space in
order to get the most out of this though
you need the waves to be big so the oven
designers made the cooking space just
the right size so when the waves bounce
off the other side they line up with
themselves then the two waves combine to
make one huge wave unfortunately now the
peaks are always in the same place quick
fix they put in a turntable to move your
food around so you don't have cold spots
in there okay so in summary and as
simple as humanly possible the
electricity comes in from the wall goes
into the transformer for a boost goes
into the magnetron to make microwaves
shines into the cooking space and is
absorbed by the water in your food
heating it from the inside
all of which happens in a fraction of a
second you'll probably never look at a
microwave oven the same again
what's the craziest thing you've ever
tried to put in a microwave oven let us
know in the comments and until next time
remember it's okay to be a little crazy
you